[Music]
sarah is in fresno california hi sarah
welcome to the ramsay show
hi
hey what's up
okay hi um how are you two doing today
great how can we help okay so in
september i applied for a mortgage fair
forbearance and
initially i did not tell my husband and
it went on until about this past july
i i woke up in the middle of night with
anxiety and god was pushing me to tell
him and so
i talked to him about it we have not
combined our incomes um
and i'm just i'm just overwhelmed and
don't know what to do at this point
what about
him
made you feel like the best path forward
for your safety was to lie to him
honestly i just didn't want him to get
mad and i didn't want him to know
about my spending and i was going to
only let it go on for about a month or
two so this this wasn't you being scared
of of an abusive guy or a frightening
guy it was you hiding from him yes shame
yes shame yes
um at the end of november my my stepson
passed away so i just
his son and so i just let it go because
it was a stressful time yeah okay so the
house that you and your husband live in
you're
supposed to be financially responsible
for by yourself
um well
well we
i pay the mortgage and he pays the other
other bills
but in this case you don't pay the more
don't pay the mortgage
[Laughter]
are you not paying because you don't
have any money are you not paying
because you spend out of control you
don't have and you're not saving right
yes that's it i spend out of control and
i'm not saving anything
and we have a lot of debts and
five years we'll marry um six six years
next month
so how far behind are you on the
mortgage now
um about sixteen thousand dollars um the
forbearance is over and the past due has
been added to the end of my term
so i have to start remaking payments and
so you're current you're current right
now
yes the 16 got laid on the back
yes
so he knows all of this
yes i i discussed it with him and i've
been asking if we could just combine our
incomes and do a budget and we talked
about all of our expenses but
i have the every dollar app and i just i
just want to be able to do everything
with him
and it's just hard
it's just hard getting him to sit down
with me and do a budget
but hold on
you've been cheating on him for a year
yeah right and so i i can imagine his
trepidation and sit down at the table
with you
and be like oh okay it's all cool you
see what i'm saying
he's gonna need some time to heal man
you've been lying to him
and he's especially through a trauma
right and so i
have you you said we discussed it that's
usually a word for we passed along
information back and forth
have you sat down and said i wronged you
and i'm sorry
no i haven't
okay in in our world in the financial
world the phrase we use for this is
financial infidelity
yeah okay that's why john said you
cheated on him because it's a breach of
trust similar to
not the same but similar to
sexual infidelity
um and so this is what you're dealing
with this is a pretty serious
schism
canyon
scar
in euros relationship that we've got to
work to heal
okay
yes and so um
uh uh
now
i don't know john you can throw this out
i i don't expect him and you don't
either i don't think anybody in this
discussion expects him to trust you
instantly blindly that's right there's
no reason to he'd be nuts if he did yeah
that would be weird okay but can we
rebuild communication and can we rebuild
trust yes we can and the best way to do
that is to work on your money together
and both of you are watching everything
the other one does because we are doing
this together all of his spending all of
your spending all of the bills are all
accessible to both of you because we are
working our house our plan together and
so get it you know um
maybe the way to work on it is this um
i'm with john you start maybe with an
apology to lead the conversation this
time hey
i missed you over i didn't i didn't want
to i was i did it out of shame but it
doesn't matter it's just the same thing
it's uh it's a breach of trust and i'm
really sorry
now i'm scared i'm scared about two
things
number one i'm scared because i don't
want to do this by myself anymore i need
some help
i want to be i want to be engaged i want
to be accountable i want everybody to
know what's going on and so i need your
help and i'm scared that if we're not
working together and you're not seeing
everything it's going to be hard for you
to rebuild trust
so if we were to work together it would
be you helping me
and simultaneously
you
get to trust me over time because you
see us doing this together the right way
this money stuff
how's that conversation go
a lot better than it had in the past
because i want you to catch the magic of
what dave just told you that
conversation is entirely about you
you're not sitting down across the table
saying hey you need to be doing this
stuff for me it's not that it's you
saying i screwed up i'm scared will you
help me will you walk with me
and i want to rebuild trust and a good
way to do that is for you to see
everything
while we're doing it together
yeah that would be amazing yeah i i i
know i take i take responsibility
absolutely because it's my
responsibility but you know we're not
here to shame you no it's just
the beauty of a conversation like that
is that you don't have to throw any
grenades on his side of the table you
can hold them all in your hands
and uh that takes you to some really
cool places
so um i i i think you got a shot at this
if that kind of a conversation does not
bring the two of you to start working on
your money together you need marriage
counseling
okay
and here's one thing i want you to try
okay you may need it anyway yeah i i
think you're going to anyway because
you've been through a trauma he lost his
son right y'all been through a lot
yeah um and he found out he might be
losing his home right that's been that's
a scary season he's been through
um here's what i want you to do
personally
i want you to go to home depot or lowe's
or something and i want you to buy a
cinder block and i want you to put a
piece of duct tape on it that just says
i lied about my money
to the man that i love
and i want you to carry it around for 15
or 20 minutes at your house and feel how
heavy that sucker is and your shoulders
are going to get heavy and your hands
are going to hurt and then i want you to
take it into the backyard set it down
rip that duct tape off of it and never
pick that shame up again
fair
yes because if every time you sit down
to talk about budget that shame comes
back up you're going to get feisty again
you're going to blame you're going to
poke you're going to hide and we need
that shame to be away and secrets man
that that's the that's the gasoline for
shane there are secrets when i filed
bankruptcy and i was 28 it was my fault
i was stupid
i had to do that exact exercise i had to
set it down and go
i did something stupid i am not stupid
there you go
it's not an identity thing this is the
ramsay show